He's one of the most successful smugglers in us history in the late 1970s and
early 1980s, Louisiana native Barry seal made a fortune trafficking,
unbelievable quantities of cocaine onto American soil.
A born pilots seal was able to, for years to our wit the DEA, the FBI,
us customs,
and any other federal agency that tried to stop him loosely connected to Pablo
Escobar's notorious median cartel seal lived a life of adventure,
riches and excitement in far off lands until suddenly
he didn't in 1983 seal was called boasting in a wiretap and undated for
smuggling facing a minimum of 10 years. He realized his only escape was to flip,
to go from being America's top drug runner to its top da informants.
There was a decision that would lead him from the battlefields of Nicaragua to
the rain forest. South side,
met a yean and to bring him face-to-face with Pablo Escobar,
a twisted Funhouse mirror ride through the darker side of the 1980s.
This is the story of Barry seal Louisiana's cocaine.
Cowboy.
It was a sultry day in Baton Rouge when Adler Berryman seal known all his life
as Barry seal was born on the 16th of July, 1939.
And that is one of the last uncontested facts you're going to hear during this
entire story,
thanks to his pension for aliases possible connections with the CIA and love of
spinning tall tales.
It's surprisingly hard to get a definitive account of Barry seal's life.
We found sources that contend he was nothing but a glorified con man, others,
that insist he was a long-term CIA asset.
And yet others that implicate him in everything from the Bay of pigs to the JFK
assassination. In other words,
we've had to do a lot of picking and choosing with this one,
trying to tease a narrative out of a true mess of sources while we've
hopefully got something approaching the truth.
Please do keep one crucial fact in minds.
No one on earth could talk as much crap as Barry seal and as Barry
seal sure liked to hear himself talk from his earliest days,
the young boy was obsessed with the planes that buzz through the skies above
Baton Rouge by his teenage years seal was spending all of his free time hanging
around the app or talking to any pilot who'd PAMs and minds.
It helps that even at this young age,
he was naturally charismatic with a storyteller's instinct and an affable charm,
but charisma wasn't Barry seal's only talent age,
just 15 seals started pilot lessons.
It turns out to be such a natural that his instructor was letting him fly solo
after only eight hours of training. Because of course,
it's not like letting an untrained teenager take command of flying bond,
could somehow go wrong and go wrong. It really could've. Despite his talent,
Ceil was a crazy risk taker pushing his aircraft to its very limits.
His instructor even noted. He seemed incapable of grasping how his actions had,
but apparently borderline sociopathy.
Isn't a disqualification for flying in Louisiana because seal was a qualified
pilot. By the time he was 16, when he graduated high school in 1957,
his yearbook noted. He was full of fun, full of folly.
How writes his classmates would turn out to be after dropping out of college
seal, set up a business,
flying advertising banners over Baton Rouge on August the 10th, 1958.
While trying to show off seal misjudged,
a maneuver and sentence plane sign into the ground.
The young pilot lost several teeth and spent a week in the hospital for any
other teenager.
This could have been the wake-up call the moments when they realized they
weren't invisible and the bad things could really happen, but not Barry seal.
In 1961 seal joined the Louisiana national guard signing up for additional pilot
training there. He got so good at pushing an aircraft past its limits.
So good at executing death defying stunts that he could fly in almost any
conditions. It was a skill that it put to good use in the Vietnam,
or would he, depending on who you ask a seal,
either spent the mid sixties flying special forces missions in Vietnam,
or he spent the time as an army reserve in the us quietly improving his pilot
skills and lying about his military service. Both tails seem plausible.
Seal would turn out to be such an expert at flying through the jungle that it's
tempting to think that he must've had prior experience. On the other hand,
his military record shows no signs of duty in Asia, let alone in a combat zone,
whatever the truth it's generally agreed that by 1967 seal had been honorably
discharged and got himself a job flying with the commercial airline TWA. There,
he became one of the youngest command pilots that the fleet had ever seen,
but his initial excitement soon wore off flying commercial.
You were forbidden from doing the stunts that seal loved so much for an
adrenaline junkie. Being a professional pilot was like URI,
professionally watching paint dry, no seal needed excitement in his life.
Some outlet to stave off the boredom.
Luckily adventure was just around the corner.
Why don't you?
72 Barry seal was a twice divorced pilot with a string of failing businesses and
Baton Rouge and deep desire to do something interesting.
It was at this point so that he met Marie Morris Kessler.
Kessler had some connections in Mexico with a bunch of anti-Castro Cubans.
These guys needed a capable pilots to fly 1,350 pounds of plastic
explosives down from the United States.
And while they were willing to pay big here,
it was the excitement seal had been craving the danger.
What else was this overweight?
Under-stimulated schlub from Louisiana going to do with such an offer?
Of course he said, yes. And that's how on July?
The first 1972 Barry seal came to be sat in a hotel room with seven other
accomplices.
When us customs agents broke down the door and arrested the lot of them,
customers, Cubans, that just been a front for a federal sting operation.
And now the government was going throw the book at Barry seal.
And the summer of 1974,
the case went to trial by now seal had been fired from his job at TWA.
Who'd heard all about his aborted Mexican adventure.
He'd lost most of his savings on legal fees. And on top of that,
as it now looks like it was going to go to prison.
The only reason he didn't was thanks to a miracle years later seal would boast
a CIA buddies, stepped in and quashed the trial on grounds of national security.
But the reality is that seal almost certainly had no connections with the agency
at this point. And it's not like the trial never happens.
The case played out in public court for five days. No.
What really saved seal wasn't friends in high places,
but good old fashioned governments in competence during the trial,
the prosecution brandished an assault rifle before the jury claiming that it
belonged to seal the defense pointed out that this was prejudicing. The jury,
the judge declared a mistrial and seal walked free.
There was the single luckiest break Barry seal would get in his entire life.
Had the government's prosecution team not been so dumb.
There'd be no story for this video at all.
That same year seal married Deborah and Woah with whom he eventually had three
children. But while it was great to be not just a married man,
but a free married man seal was still in a bad place.
DWA wouldn't take him back.
Thanks to the smuggling trial had been blacklisted with the other airlines too.
He was a broke unemployable, fantastically,
talented pilot with nothing to do,
but that was going to soon change as 1975.
Dawn's demand for talented unscrupulous American pilots South of the border was
about to explode.
It was the beginning of the era of cocaine and it would transform Barry seal's
life.
In 1971,
Richard Nixon stood before Congress to declare drug use was America's public
enemy. Number one, it was the beginning of the war on drugs.
Just two years later in 1973, the DEA was created,
but if Nixon thought the drug scene was bad in 1971,
with all those hippies smoking pot,
things were about to get a whole lot worse. Cocaine had been around for a while,
but it had always been too expensive too out of step with the 1960s,
but mass production methods improved. The price began to drop.
Even as the purity went up by the time Barry seal was in court,
cocaine was no longer something only Hollywood royalty you could afford.
And as the USA turned away from pot and LSD demand for cocaine was beginning to
creep up. However,
it would take a very specific set of circumstances to 10 Coke into the linchpin
of Barry seal's life. A specific set of circumstances in a specific country.
Columbia from the outside Columbia in the early 1970s,
lived relatively stable with a growing economy and little violence,
but this outward appearance mollusks,
a deeply fractured society or power was concentrated in the hands of a tiny
elite since 1957. The country's two major parties.
The liberals and conservatives have been in a power sharing agreements that
blocks everyone else out of politics.
The reason for this had been some of the goals that violencia decade long
undeclared civil war between two parties that had killed 200,000 people.
But while the 1957 agreements that ended the war, the fighting had still left.
The nation deeply traumatized level NCR had been marked by extreme
brutality.
Police were publicly decapitated and their heads used a soccer balls to give
just a single chilling example.
Pablo Escobar had grown up among this spending his first decade in a world of
gruesome lynchings and state sanctioned murder.
He also lived with the aftermath with the economy bottomed out in the early
1960s, as many of the poorest turning to crime to survive yet.
Even this potent mix of traumatized desperately poor people locked out of
political power, might not have exploded.
Had it not been for sheer bad luck,
just as cocaine was starting to bring in serious money.
The traditional Mexican gangs that supplying the States had been driven
underground by a government crackdown down in Columbia.
Web blue was actually produced. Criminal, saw a chance to fill up the void.
The first warning sign of things to come came in November,
1975 when Colombian police seized 600 kilograms of cocaine in retaliation,
drug gangs,
gruesomely murdered 40 people in an event known as the medid massacre,
but the real turning points came in 1977.
The wealthy show of brothers approached Pablo Escobar.
Now a local drug kingpin and are uniting all the gangs in Midian under a single
umbrella group.
One that were control every stage of cocaine from production to trafficking
to distribution.
It was the beginnings of the median cartel soon to become so powerful and so
dangerous.
It made the Sinaloa cartel look like a bunch of promising girls Scouts,
but the median cartel would soon become something else to Barry.
How embarrassing.
You came to be employed by Escobar. Is there a right place,
right time sort of deal. By 1976,
the disgraced pilot started a smuggling operation flying down to Honduras and
returning with marijuana.
It was small time enough that no one bothered seal allowing him to get plenty of
practice using the legs and buyers of the JAG in Louisiana coastline for drug
drops, but it wasn't small enough to keep them completely under the radar.
In late 1979 seal touchdown in Honduras to find his planes suddenly surrounded
by cops. It was only thanks to dumb luck that he wasn't flying.
And he popped that day. Although police did find an illegal rifle.
Thanks to that rifle. Barry spent the next seven months in a Honduran jail.
Incredibly.
This would actually turn out to be his lucky break on the flight home.
In July of 1980 seal found himself sat next to Roger Reeves,
a professional drug smuggler with connections inside the MedImmune cartel Reeves
was at the forefront of this new era of cocaine.
He told seal how the cartel was investigating an islands and light aircraft.
How small planes would soon become the lifeblood of smuggling.
If seal just happens to know any talented pilots of such aircraft. Well,
that pilots might be able to make themselves a lot of money.
It was an offer that seal couldn't refuse before long barrier seal with
smuggling cocaine for the MedImmune cartel.
And it was everything that Reeves the promised seals income exploded overnight.
By 1983, he would have made over $25 million.
The thing is he was worth it. Even in the early 1980s,
you couldn't just fly into U S airspace from South America and not expect to
receive the deepest cavity search in customs history just have been undetected.
You have to fly so low over the Gulf of Mexico that you were almost touching the
water. And even then you might still get picked up by radar. So yeah,
to fly slow and make sure you came in near where the offshore oil fields were.
So any board air traffic controller who glimpsed you on his screen would assume
you were just a helicopter returning from a rig vitally.
You have to drop your shipment without getting caught. By now.
Barry seal knew the swampy tango coastline of Louisiana,
better than anyone he would fly in at night with his lights off using night
vision goggles to find his way using a walkie-talkie into GPS tracker hit radio
is men and exactly where to find the product.
Then it drop it into the dark Bayou below and fly away into the night sky.
Shortly after a boat would haul the cocaine out of the swamp,
where it would be loaded onto cars and driven to Miami.
It was a complicated setup, but seal pulls it off.
None of his men were caught in the act for the DEA.
Still used to a world where smuggling shoving blowups a mule's and hoping for
the best seal is advanced tactics or left them dizzy.
This was smuggling as an art form,
designed to impress seals employers and met a year.
Not that seal had ever met the guy who's paying his salary.
All of seals contacts with the cartel had been through intermediaries.
Pablo Escobar had never seen a picture of him.
Never heard his real name only is alias El Gordo or the fat man.
It would be this crucial missing piece of information that would both spare
Barry seal a lifetime in prison and sign his death sentence.
[Inaudible].
Lucille was a clever smuggler.
He wasn't as clever as he thought he was for one thing while seal knew to use
only payphones to contact people.
He was far too lazy to keep randomly choosing new payphones.
So when the DEA decided to start collecting info on him,
they simply wiretapped the 10 payphones that he used the most and built their
case that way for another barrier seal,
also like to boast to anyone and everyone,
it was this last trait that would destroy his life. In 1981,
a DEA agent wearing a wire, walked into a Baton Rouge bar,
went up to Barry seal and was all like, Hey,
you don't like the sort of phone guy that has really awesome stories about
smuggling drugs with a blue Escobar. Want to tell me about them? I mean,
if you could lean in towards me and speak clearly,
that would also be super helpful.
Incredibly this word seal started spouting off his mouth and ended the
conversation promising the undercover agent that it smuggles in Briggs.
It was the beginning of the endless,
although the DEA and FBI would need over another year to build an airtight case.
That one conversation was the start of Barry seal's downfall.
The boot finally dropped in March of 1983.
That month seal was indicted for cocaine smuggling. The following year, March,
1984, the trial began a 10 year sentence hovering over his head.
That's a long decade of boredom of being stuck behind bars away from
flying away from the life that seal loved so much panics seal
promised to turn informants to give the DEA, whatever they want it. Oh,
we like to think the DEA agents chuckles Amar, can you give us?
And seal's answer was Pablo Escobar. It was a desperate gamble.
Although seal works for the MedImmune cocktail.
I'd never met Escobar had no idea how to even go about setting the drug Lord up.
The DEA were likewise unconvinced. They shoved CLF phone and basically said,
go and then breathe it. So seal call to connection.
And the cartel pretended to be a pilot called Ellis McKenzie,
who was super into the idea of flying enormous quantities of Coke to the USA.
Somehow the desperate bluff worked.
The connection agreed to set up a meeting between seal and Escobar himself.
Suddenly the DEA was no longer just looking at Navigant American smuggler,
but dismantling the entire Meridian in cartel based with such a prize.
They agree to plea deal on the 8th of April, 1984 seal walk,
take semi free man onto an American airfield and took off for Columbia that
evening.
He found himself at the Choa brother's estate face-to-face with the entire
cartel leadership.
It was the first time the DEA informants had ever met Escobar face to face.
Luckily Escobar had no idea unless McKenzie was the same person as their older
pilot, El Gordo had been enamored by the Americans.
The drug Lord outlined his plans do Ellis.
He would fly 15,000 kilograms of cocaine to America and preparation for selling
it. The 1984 Olympics to load up. He wouldn't come to Columbia,
but to a military base in Nicaragua,
which the Sandinista regime was renting out to Escobar.
This all sounded fine to seal who must've been desperate just to get the meeting
concluded and get out of that. But if it all sounded fine to him,
it was going to sound way more than just fine to the CIA.
When word got to the agency about Barry seal's adventure,
things were going to get crazy.
Never.
To unravel when seal first fluids in Nicaragua.
Although the Midian cartel had supposedly cleared it with the Sandinista
government.
Someone had forgotten to tell the troops on the ground seal was shot down over
the jungle, arrested and thrown in, in the Karakia in jail.
While Escobar's contacts within the government would get him released it.
Unfortunately wouldn't be before the DEA found out, unfortunately,
the da wouldn't be able to spring seal by themselves.
Instead they contacted the CIA for help only to watch the case be taken out of
their hands at the moment. Barry seal crash landed in Nicaragua.
The Sandinista government was American enemy. Number one,
a bunch of left-wing rebels overthrown Nicaragua's dictator.
The Sandinistas were close to both Cuba and the Soviet union as a result of the
CIA and the white house had spent years trying to discredit them even illegally
funding, right wing death squads, known as Contreras to wage a brutal civil war.
But while the American public already knew the Sandinistas were communists,
they didn't know they were also cocaine traffickers.
If the CIA could prove this support for regime change would surely grow.
But the upshot was that once Barry seal arrived back in the United States,
it was to find his mission had changed no longer.
Was he going to just act as DEA mole in the medium cartel,
he was going to have to use secret cameras to photograph the massive drug deal
seal, begs them not to make him do this. He knew the MedImmune cartel.
He knew what they would do to him. If they suspected he was an informant.
If he was lucky, they might shoot him. If he was unlucky,
that slowly tortured him to death and leave his mutilated body hanging from a
tree. But the CIA would determined either seal,
take these photos or go straight to prison. On June the 26th, 1984,
Barry seal boarded,
a plane equipped with two hidden cameras and flew back to Nicaragua.
It was likely the longest day of his entire life.
When seal landed in the fields, he was immediately surrounded by armed soldiers.
Then one of the secret cameras, malfunctioned and started making loud noises,
meaning see, I'll have to find an excuse to gum the engines to cover the sounds.
But the most heart-stopping moments was likely when a vehicle pulled up next to
the plane, then out step to Pablo Escobar. For whatever reason,
the drug Lord himself has come to not just watch the loading,
but personally helped through duffle bags of cocaine into the hangar.
It was Barry seal's death sentence. Oh sure.
He would physically live a while longer,
long enough to fly his plane back to the U S but the moment Escobar was caught
on camera.
Sack of cocaine in hand seal was as dead as a man who knowingly
has terminal cancer. When the CIA saw seals photos, they were ecstatic.
So ecstatic.
They promptly leaked them to the press blowing sales cover by mid July, 1984,
the Medellin cartel placed a million dollar bounty on seals. Hat.
This would be bad enough if seal were able to go into hiding,
he still needed to make his court date. On January.
The 20th was 1986 seal went on trial in Baton Rouge for smuggling cocaine.
While his plea deal mentors maximum sentence was fairly low.
The judge still decided to go all out. Neil was sentenced to six months,
community service in a salvation army center.
It would be forbidden from carrying a gun forbidden from protecting himself from
the wrath of Escobar. And then the judge did something so utterly stupid.
It's tempting to think that it was deliberate there in open court.
The judge read out the address of the center.
Barry seal would spend six months in it.
Doesn't take a genius to figure out what happened next. A couple of weeks later,
a gang of Colombian hitmen crossed into the United States and headed up to
Louisiana on February the 19th, 1986,
Barry seal pulls his car into its parking Bay outside the salvation army sends
up before he could open the door to Hitman.
Calmly walked over and aimed there's some machine guns at long.
Last Barry seal's legendary luck had run out seal was dead even before
the men finished firing. Although the authorities would cash as assassins.
The game was still over down South Pablo Escobar would evade justice for another
seven years bringing Columbia to its knees before finally getting gunned down
himself on a MedImmune rooftop in Nicaragua with the CIA's attempts to
destabilize the Sandinistas failed.
The party remained in power until 1990 before returning to government in 2006 at
the time of writing best still Nicaragua's leading political party as for the
war on drugs. Well, it relocated Columbia today is relatively peaceful,
but you only have to look at Mexico to see drug violence is still very much with
us, but what of Barry seal? Well,
even now he remains a fascinating figure and immoral adventurer with a near
suicidal disregard for his own safety.
But he's also interesting for another reason for two or three short years,
seal stood at the very center of the war on drugs.
The point West smuggling politics, poverty, desperation, and underhand,
CIA tactics,
all met his actions had consequences that stretched all the way up to the Reagan
white house that echoed through Bogota's corridors of power for years to come.
Certainly not bad for a fat kid from Baton Rouge.
Barry seal may have been a loud mouth, a show off and a convicted drug smuggler,
but he was also a man willing to pay almost any price for an interesting life.
It's fitting. Then that's in the end, the price he paid was the ultimate one.
So I really hope you found the video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos, just like this several times a week.
Thank you for watching.